So i promise to destroy your world in
ten days the galaxy needs its guardians
you said this would be a relaxing holiday
the summer of love today today it will go down
in history and thunder begins today we'll fight
this is my vow oh god shrunk down them they
may not be catastrophic to the whole universe
do you swear to god the nine realms i swear and
do you swear to preserve the peace i swear one of
the early decisions we made at marvel studios
was bringing on thor and we always knew he
wanted to find an amazing performer who had the
chops to perform this character as we saw him
we looked the world over and we found chris
hemsworth this world is my punishment it's my
punishment for my endless pursuit of glory the way
chris did it we thought okay this is gonna work
it's really really just impressive to watch
him work he's so committed and works so hard
he has such incredible comedic talent as well just
drink i like it another not the best you can do
this is what it's all about you know
it's coming meeting the people who
love the characters more than anyone
and so that's a very very special thing
it really is inspiring because he is
brave enough to try things and see what
sticks mind-blowing you know it's going to be
incredible what a classic forward adventure
and flick
oh flick too hard damn it
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
thor love and thunder trailer video there's some
new footage a lot of you've also been asking
me to do a video about beta ray bill where
is he we've already seen him in the mcu before
like he's already been canonized to the mcu so
a lot of people are just waiting to see him in
an actual movie and i'll explain what's going
on with guardians of the galaxy during the movie
and guardians of the galaxy 3 the guardians of
the galaxy holiday special which also coming
later this year james gunn has been hyping up
if you're brand new to the channel we're doing a
giveaway for thor love and thunder imax tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about the movie on
the video i'll name a winner during this video too
but just starting with some of the new scenes from
the trailer obviously we have all the thor versus
celestials just funny scenes with him crashing
through them using the space ghost like you get
a much better shot of the ghost just causing all
kinds of trouble in the godhead meeting here
at omnipotent city if it wasn't clear all
these scenes where you see thor versus zeus has
meant all the other gods that's taking place at
the mcu version of the godhead like a meeting of
all the most powerful gods not every single god
but the most powerful gods and the reason
why the celestials would be there or they'd
have representatives there from the celestial
host is just because it's a meeting of the most
powerful cosmic figures there's a version of
this that happens during the thanos infinity
gauntlet storyline that they kind of skipped over
during the actual movie version of infinity war
where odin at that time was still alive
met with a lot of the most powerful gods
inside the 616 universe but they get trapped by
thanos on asgard when he breaks the rainbow bridge
but this is kind of meant to be the movie version
of that they're paying it off as part of this gorr
storyline because he's trying to kill all these
gods so of course they'd be meeting to try and
figure out what to do about him and for those of
you asking yes gorr would become powerful enough
eventually to kill the celestials the verse
of the necro sword in the movie is going to
be a little bit different i've already explained
how the shadow realm is meant to be an alternate
dimension that thor explains in a previous clip
that we got from the movie and it just seems like
the necrosword is filled with energy from that
dimension and something about that different
type of cosmic energy makes it powerful enough to
kill gods in the mcu but like the reason why you
don't see konshu in the background here with the
egyptian pantheon they explained during moon night
that they'd banished him from their presence so no
matter where they were meeting they wouldn't allow
him to be there you see a little bit of behind
the scenes footage of thor swinging stormbreaker
around during one of the scenes that knew asgard
fighting gorr's army there's also some brand new
footage of him with the guardians of the galaxy
saying the galaxy needs their guardians and
it's as they get ready to leave and go off on
their own to go find the 2014 version of gamora
when thor goes his separate way with the goats in
valkyrie back to new asgard in the newer version
of the costume before he finds out about gorr
the god butcher but you may have seen some talk
about beta ray bill recently in your timelines
the reason why people are talking about him is
because kevin feige was talking about introducing
other variants of thor in the future like other
versions besides chris hemsworth and natalie
portman store so a lot of websites took that to
be a reference to their long-term plans for secret
wars avengers 5 avengers 6 more multiverse stuff
which is more variants of a lot of the characters
in general from the avengers movies the cool
connection to comic book secret wars is because
they very literally did the thor core with many
many alternate versions of the character and they
were basically like god emperor doom's glorified
police force on battle world but in the mcu if
you're talking about alternate versions of thor
like you have frog thor that we saw on loki cannot
wait to see him come back in some form beta ray
bill would be like the next biggest most different
version of thor you could introduce who's not just
like another version of chris hemsworth playing
old man king thor with the destroyer arm or just
like another variant fun fact too chris hemsworth
actually did the voice for frog thor even though
it just sounded like a couple grunts coming out
of that little frog thor it was chris hemsworth
that did brand new dialogue for those grunts
but because beta ray bill was already featured
during thor ragnarok he's already been canonized
to the mcu like he's already an mcu character
in fact there have actually been a lot of other
easter eggs and deleted scenes featuring beta
ray built in the marvel movies already there have
been some beta ray build deleted scenes in earlier
marvel movies kevin feige just said they're saving
the character for a big upcoming story recently
marvel just posted the screenplay for avengers end
game there were obviously a ton of deleted scenes
and moments that didn't make it into the final
cut of the movie but one of them is actually a big
beta ray bill easter egg when the avengers go back
in time to get all the different infinity stones
you go to 2014 when they're trying to steal the
power stone during this you see a bunch of scenes
with gamora nebula and thanos of 2014 culling
half the population of an alien planet talking
to each other it's revealed in the screenplay
that this planet is actually corbin the home of
the corbinites in the home of beta ray bill now
this character that they're fighting is not beta
ray bill this is just another corbinite wearing
a giant suit of armor the corbinites themselves
don't look like beta ray build the reason why beta
ray bill looks like this is because his people
genetically modified him to become even more
powerful and defend them from anybody that sought
to do them harm think about the timeline of this
too this is happening in 2014 before the events
of thor ragnarok and during thor ragnarok we found
out that beta ray bill really was a character they
actually deleted some of his scenes early on the
reason why his head shows up on the grandmasters
tower is because he was going to be one of the
members of the contest of champions before the
hulk came along so it's implied that the
hulk defeated him when he came to sakhar
so it's implied the beta ray bill had to leave
the planet or flee when thanos killed half of the
people in exile and that's how he wound up in the
contest of champions the really cool connection to
thor 4 love and thunder beta ray bill and thor
is that in the comics when they first met each
other they actually fought in the movies right now
thor still wields stormbreaker but in the comics
that's the name of beta ray bill's hammer his
hammer looks a little bit different he was given
that hammer by odin after he defeated thor in
combat imagine how much beta ray bill would hate
thor for not protecting his people knowing that
he was supposed to become king after odin and that
the avengers gained the ability to time travel
and thor didn't use that to help the corbonites
and beta ray bill's people so early prediction
that's one reason for them to fight each other
beta ray bill would be pissed that the asgardians
were not helping them protecting them the way
they were supposed to the other funny connection
to the movies too you have to remember is that
during 2014 when beta ray bill's home planet is
busy being culled by thanos here is that it was
actually while loki was pretending to be odin also
not really being king mostly just chilling out
watching plays of himself so marvel's already done
the legwork of giving beta ray bill a really cool
backstory and a motivation that explains what he
was doing during avengers infinity war of andrew's
end game what he was doing on sakhar and the grand
masters contest of champions before the events
of ragnarok in how his backstory also connects to
what's happening at least thematically during thor
love and thunder with gorr's mission to kill all
the gods because he thinks that they're useless
and they don't actually care about their
own subjects and they'd have to say that
he either got stormbreaker or another version
of his comic accurate hammer in a different way
or they just want to save him for something like
secret wars and bring him from the multiverse he
can show up with any version of the hammer that
they want but after that introducing the character
you're really just talking about doing a version
of the loki army that we saw during loki episode 5
but with versions of thor and just calling it the
thoracore like every crazy version of thor you've
ever seen in the comics ever really want to see
some scenes with alligator loki versus frog thor
that would be fantastic but as for what's going
on with guardians of the galaxy 3 the whole idea
is that they're really trying to introduce adam
warlock and it sounds like a version of the high
evolutionary in the mcu now i don't know exactly
how they're going to explain counter-earth where
high evolutionary is supposed to have his main
base because it sounds like he's going to be the
person in the mcu who created rocket or modified
him with all that technology they might just say
that he came from a different planet instead of
saying that he came from a different universe
will poulter's going to be playing their version
of adam warlock apparently he got super buffed
for it too i'm not expecting to see him during
the guardians of the galaxy holiday special
but james gunn did say that that's going to be
canon and it will help set up what's happening
after the events of thor love and thunder but
before the beginning of guardians of the galaxy 3.
and not every single character from guardians of
the galaxy 3 will be in the holiday special like
it'll just have some of the characters we might
get a guardians of the galaxy holiday special
teaser trailer either at the marvel comic con
panel this summer or at the big disney plus day
event in september but everybody post
all your beta ray bill theories in the
comments below what do you want to see
them do with that character in the mcu
my thor love and thunder review video is allowed
to post next tuesday so look out for that
in my full thor love and thunder post credit scene
easter egg videos breakdown of the entire movie
that'll start posting after the movie actually
comes out later next week congratulations valhalla
industries you're the giveaway winner from my last
big marvel video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my brand new doctor doom
video in the mcu and click here for my full
ms marvel episode 4 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!